alexis poulain c'est notre rubrique
l'édito alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france
alors ce week end je le disais encore
une déconvenue électorale pour la
république aux marges dans les
législatives partielles ou les candidats
la république en marge ne sont pas au
second tour
oui aucun d'entre eux n'est au second
tour dans ces législatives partielles et
pourtant c'était autrefois des fiefs en
marche où il y avait des scores bien
plus haut alors certes la participation
était très faible ça pose la question
bien sûr de ces élections qui mobilise
très peu mais ça en dit long sur le
désamour de ce parti sur finalement la
dynamique qui était celle qui avait
permis à tous ces députés et un de
mettre leurs visages à côté de celui des
marines des macros et d'être élues
immédiatement à l'assemblée nationale
sans avoir auparavant fait de politiques
pour certains d'entre eux eh bien cette
fois ci c'est fini la mécanique en
marche est à l'arrêt alors du coup
alexis c'est la crise à la république en
marche
oui c'est la crise christophe castaner
qui remplace ce gilles de jambes pour
prendre la tête du groupe à l'assemblée
nationale se retrouve sur un tas de
cendres du moins une maison bien mal en
point
certains sont déjà partis s'étaient
sacha oublier pour monter à un parti
monsieur personne qui quitte ses
fonctions aurore bergé qui quitte ses
fonctions dans le groupe riposte
on voit bien que il y à là tous les
déçus finalement de la république en
marche
or verger qui disait avoir tout donné
pour ce mouvement et qui finalement ne
récupère que très peu de choses les
ambitieux s'en vont montrent leurs cours
en parallèle ou bien rejoignent le modem
parce qu'ils ont compris que cette
étiquette là serait négative dans les
échéances à venir
un parti qui a du mal à s'ancrer dans le
territoire et les prochaines élections
sénatoriales régional et bien ça va être
beaucoup plus compliqué encore pour en
marche de fer est bien une
une construction réelle donc l'idée est
de partir un peu à droite à gauche au
modem ou ailleurs et finalement c'est
une stratégie qui peut être payante
parce que en marche ne s'arrête pas mais
ça devient une diaspora ou finalement
tous les députés anciennement marcheurs
vont trouver une nouvelle étiquette et
continuer d'être fidèle à emmanuel
macron pour préparer 2022
mais dans d'autres écuries alors
finalement est-ce que c'est grave pour
emmanuel macron est-ce qu'il a besoin
d'un parti pour se faire réélire ce que
finalement l'international
c'est pas une chance pour lui oui
clairement
déjà en 2010 est emmanuel macron n'a pas
eu besoin d'un parti pour se faire élire
c'était une coquille vide qui lui
permettait de dire qu'il avait un
mouvement de fédérer d'avoir là à
l'époque des gens qui y croyaient qu'ils
étaient ces marcheurs du bas qui
pensaient à que la transversalité était
une réalité pour faire du porte à porte
pour changer le monde d'une certaine
façon
tout ça s'est vite évaporé une fois
quesnel macron a été élu surtout grâce
et bien à son réseau qu'il avait pu
faire dans la banque d'affaires
dans les cercles d'affaires français la
finance internationale les français
aussi à l'étranger
donc il n'a pas besoin d'un parti et il
le sait aujourd'hui il parle même de
faire une maison commune une coalition
avec le modem et d'autres et même si en
marche et minoritaires mais ce n'est pas
grave parce que ce parti là finalement
il a vécu ça suffisait c'était
uniquement pour être élu et c'est très
grave parce que aujourd'hui on a un
homme en france qui concentre à peu près
tous les pouvoirs emmanuel macron
président isolé à à l'elysée simplement
il est enfermé dans ce palais avec des
cordes de crs autour de lui et il décide
absolument de tout avec un gouvernement
qu'il y à aussi est aux ordres
regardez comme gérald darmanin essaye de
mettre aux ordres
la presse avec cette nouvelle doctrine
pour empêcher les journalistes de faire
le travail lors des manifestations
regardez monsieur dupont moretti garde
des sceaux attaqué par deux syndicats de
magistrats aujourd'hui parce que trop de
conflits d'intérêts avec ce monsieur et
les procès qui arrive de nicolas sarkozy
regardez la façon dont la police a été
utilisé aussi pour bien asseoir un ordre
républicain pour certains mais parfois
un ordre bien violent lors des
manifestations des gilet jaune tout ça
ne va pas et c'est très grave
et aujourd'hui emmanuel macron dia
qu'est ce qu'il fait et bien il ne lui
reste plus que son image donc il se
réinvente encore une fois changements de
costumes changement de ton changement de
braquet le ni droite ni gauche a vécu ça
c'était pour 2017
aujourd'hui il devient le président
français qui agit un peu partout dans le
monde discours à l'onu la libye
le liban un peu partout il est là pour
résoudre les problèmes ou en créer de
nouveaux mais aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
attendre 2022 et croire que la vème
république est un régime démocratique
c'est grave et la démocratie ce n'est
pas ça merci beaucoup alexis poulain
pour votre et littoraux je rappelle que
vous êtes éditorialistes